how did you guys go about putting
together your list what kind of of the
heart did you tap I I have some which is
like I I have a very great attachment to
for nostalgic reasons I have ones where
it's like I can eat this in any
situation any time of the day and then I
have ones which are like this is kind of
a secret Banger you know these are ones
where it's like it's it's not the number
one secret Banger
[__] number it's the it's not a number
one charting kit but it it has a cult
fan base type of deal you know cult fan
base in your yeah C Fair Bas my heart m
is non-stop bangers just now that's what
I
call bangers we'll be the charge of that
nonstop bangers That's What I Call food
that's what the album cover is going to
be my 3 by three yeah for me it's just
like these are the dishes where I was
thinking about you know how sometimes
you like crave a dish and then sometimes
you think about eating that and you're
like I'm not really feeling that these
all of these dishes I could eat anytime
no matter what where I am where I am me
too I feel like decided like you hand
this to me I eat it yeah if you hand
these stuff to me I always got time I
don't need to be craving it cuz I always
am craving it no matter what uh okay
we're all on the same we're all on the
same base level in that regard but now
it's up to what we actually CH we have
to discuss but let's not let's not judge
each other let's not judge each other
right let's remain what's what's the fun
in that let's remain civil in all are
you saying we're like 180 something
episodes in and we're suddenly not going
to judge each other anymore I just think
that we should you know understand each
other a bit more sometimes I like we
don't do that enough on try you telling
this to yourself no no no I just I just
know that I'm you guys are going to say
mean things so I just think you say I
don't think you're going to say any mean
things about mine one mine are all just
[__] off what did you do like oh pizza
and I like I like I like chicken and I
like U um [__] TI pretty much pretty
much I swear to God if you have the most
basic list I'm going to be so pissed off
yeah then we're going to criticize
you're going to look at my list and
you're going to be like yeah this is
gone there we're going to criticize you
for being too there has to be a food
that you look at and you go objectively
I know this is not like the top food of
all time for other people but for me
it's a banger yeah I don't
know I don't know if there is I was
trying to think about if I have any hot
food takes and I have no f t What do
they do to you when you were a monk huh
what he's too content all right uh shall
we get started with the list I believe
we are once again going to be having
trashbox Kun up and about we're
resurrecting him right now
he's stuffed with our names we have to
we have to create a seance to to to get
him back from the dead so if this is
your first 3x3 episode if you don't know
what a 3X3 is it's a it's a list of
basically a uh as it sounds like a
3X3 which is nine which is nine to top
nine Foods math of us occasionally a
math all right all right first up is
God all right I swear to God if we go in
this order all right all right all right
let's let's I kind of don't want to go
last let's let's get my list up let's
get my list up all right what the [__]
am I looking at
here so let me let me explain this right
now because okay hold on okay oh no
maybe maybe just leave it there we'll do
both do both we do both we'll do both
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
okay what okay okay so let's go in order
so from top left to right we have uh
padow okay uh which is My Thai comfort
food uh cow to white people right say
white yeah yeah we have uh McDonald's
breakfast oh my God uh specifically the
Ed like okay so Pizza Hut had this
limited edition run the cross had this
limited edition run that I discovered
when I was a kid and I still internalize
ize and remember this to this day it's
called The Edge it's not on offer
anymore but I I dream about this [__] if
that if they bring this back I am going
I am flying all the way to England or
America just so I can eat this again but
you have to have Pizza Hut it's the edge
okay let's not get on it right now let's
just all right let's move on then uh we
have any you you I don't care what
chocolate it is you are a chocolate
Fiend I don't care what chocolate it is
you put it in easteregg form I don't
know it just tastes 10 times better I
don't know why I could eat Easter eggs
all day obviously lasagna that should
not be
a uh I kind of realized this when I was
making this list but I just like wings
not like fake Wings just like I just
what is fake Wings you know what fake
wings are I don't know what you mean by
fake Wings what do you mean by fake
Wings boneless wings they're not fake
Wings they're very much real I I I I
just [__] love chicken wings and I
love I've loved them everything since I
was a kid chng um on the bottom left
that's not specifically Sushi that's
just salmon niri oh okay just salmon
salmon salmon [__] okay no tuna no white
fish nothing like that okay no got it uh
on the bottom it is smoked meat American
barbecue like spare ribs and [__] all
right BG yeah uh and on the bottom right
is instant Ramen Shin instant Ramen uh
Shin specifically or just
Ramen I might come out a little bit of
swinging here all right gapow honestly
not not the best Tha food so much better
Tai food down there I I will say that
the reason I put grapal on uh isn't
because I thought it was isn't because
it's I think it's the best Ty okay that
was a bold thing for me to say to a
time let me say you really came out
really Conor really said let me tell you
let me teach you about your own culture
let me just tell you right now
food you have better food than this guy
this is not your strongest fighter
that's what I'm saying okay here's the
thing grapal right if you go to a tire
restaurant right I think every like
everyone who has like who has like a
grew up with a Cuisine they have this
it's it's like the test about if you go
to a restaurant of a certain qued
everyone has like that dish to test the
quality of that restaurant it's like a
steak for like like other places yeah
yeah sure to me I order always I always
order the grapal first as like the
Baseline test of like if this is good if
you can make this slap probably most
things on this menu absolutely [__]
slap because guow is like to me like the
Thai comfort food right everyone knows
how to make it everyone knows how to
make it you can find it pretty much in
most Street places in most places every
you go in Thailand this is available
right so to me this is not only like my
comfort food every time I go to Thailand
it's not like the food I always I always
am like raring to eat but to me this is
the Baseline taste test of everything
that Thai food represents and you need
it's it's like Bas basically like you
know when Gordon Ramsey ask someone to
cook an omelette you know if you can't
cook this correctly I do not trust you
to handle anything else about my Cuisine
you know I think for me Gap how leveled
up you know like that uh that picture of
uh uh Donald Duck when he has a boner
and he's in the
air me when I when I started putting the
fish or the what's the fish sauce is it
fish sauce yeah the fish sauce on it I
was like holy [__] this is like a
different dish now okay so you need to
put the uh yeah the fish sauce with like
the fresh Chili's chocol it was like a
different I was like holy [__] this
tastes so much better oh yeah yeah yeah
that I mean that's that's what they
serve it with in Thailand yeah and I I
didn't know that cuz obviously when
you're in like a British restaurant they
won't give you the cuz it does smell
horrific oh it does well not horic it
smells nice but it's just so strong yeah
and even like a tiny little container
but when I started adding it to it I was
like wait yeah galaxy brain moment like
I'm like this food is so much better now
yeah pretty slabs and like you know in
terms of like Southeast Asian kind of
like
rivalry um me and me get into like
[__] friendship ending arguments on
which Tai versus Vietnam on which
country has the better fish Source like
okay like I I will die for N I will die
for TI fish and me's like no
I to be that my opinion is I think the
Tai one's better hell yeah hell yeah I
like the Vietnamese one too but I think
personally I prefer the Tai one can I
say that pad TI is kind of mid yeah you
can can I said okay I don't I don't like
I don't I I have you ever have you ever
seen me order pad tie no no I mean I
like Pad Thai but I it's not the best
that's like the introduction for white
people to thae food yeah TI like oh this
is kind of cool this is rather this is
kind of ethnic guys right and then you
eat it a bunch you're like wait this is
probably like the least flavorful thae
dish it it is uh I think I think one
thing about thae dishes uh like diet
thae food well I said least flavorful
tieish it still has way more flavor than
like 99% of British food that I gr yeah
I kind of I kind of realized this after
you know trying different kind of
Cuisines which is you know like Japanese
Cuisine especially and obviously British
food uh which is Tha or a lot of
Southeast Asian Cuisine is just packed
full of flavor uh which is kind of why I
think you know I really like Nando cuz
Nando was the closest thing to reminding
me of something that is not exactly you
know Tha food but has that kind of like
same same like flavor profile like we
talked about uh one of our you know
Japanese staff members who complained
that Nando had like too much flavor too
much flavor you know which is wild
that's a crime you can't you can't
describe who like that that's [__] up
and to me like Thai food has always been
you know now that I've tried different
Cuisines it's it's like the ingredients
we can get in Thailand aren't the same
as [__] wag you beef or like you know
some of the pork sausages we can get in
England but we make up for that [__] by
just chucking a [__] ton of spices and a
[__] ton of meat uh sorry a [__] ton of
like chilies and flavor in it and that's
how we make up uh make up for that and
uh sometimes more is more and that's
fine sometimes sometimes adding more
flavor is great like let's not not redu
EG all right so gal makes sense uh
explain the [__] sausage egg
McMuffin do I need to explain the
sausage egg McMuffin okay in a in a
[__] 3x3 though this is like a die
ride or die food yeah yeah um mean I
like it I actually had it yesterday oh
my God I mean I like it don't get me
wrong I'm not going to say no to one did
you did you get it delivered though or
did you go to the store you can't get it
delivered I just feel like it's a
different item when it's delivered uh I
sometimes get it delivered you know when
when I'm hung over when I'm hung
over dude it has like a five minute
window of being good the egg wait which
one do you get do you get which which
which McMuffin do you get the sausage
and egg McMuffin with the hash browns I
I could include the hash browns in this
but it is it is the set as a whole the
sa sausage egg McMuffin and the hash
brown you know what you know what I'm a
[__] fiend for this there are more
times where I order two of them than
when I just get one one does not satisfy
me the double or do you do the single if
I can get the double I'll get the double
you get one double over two singles I
I'll get two doubles
two that's four sausage patties dog they
are so good I'm sorry I was familiar
with your game guys you know what okay
okay this might this might be a hot take
I genu I generally do not care about
McDonald's that much compared to their
breakfast menu their breakfast menu a
few their breakfast menu to me eclipses
anything else like I actually don't
normally crave McDonald's like generally
like I know people like get deep [__]
craving for McDonald's me I'm I am
people me I'm to stop you right there G
let me to introduce an item called the
McDonald's fries when they are fresh uh
they are unbeatable unmatched as a fast
food item uh they are the best thing
known to man and also some of the
burgers I like more yeah I like I like
the burgers my problem with the
McDonald's breakfast and has been a
constant theme throughout my life and
somehow normal McDonald's doesn't do
this to me uh the breakfast items in
particular make me feel aw
I feel get the [__] out compared to the
rest of McDonald's I can eat a Big Mac I
don't know what it is about the Egg
McMuffin I love it but holy [__] do I
feel like I've been through the ringer
when I've eaten it get this I only I
only get McDonald's breakfast when I'm
like severely hunger I also also I'm
going to put I will never eat it so I'm
going to put me on the cross right now I
do not like the hash browns in the
breakfast okay I don't I
don't here's my
complaint you said that listen here's my
problem everywhere in the world I have
McDonald's they're too oily there's too
much oil in the hash brown okay
McDonald's is the one place where you I
know I know they're supposed to be oil
but they just put a little too much man
but that's what I mean like that's why
that's why I I only eat this particular
combo of sausage egg Mo mphin with the
hash brown on a morning where I'm
severely hung over cuz otherwise I feel
like [__] I know people who will go to
McDonald's and get five hash browns in
the morning I'm like how is your
all right to flip on his head McDonald's
hash brown is the only hash brown I like
okay that's that's a
fair like like to me when I get like a
full English they have the hash browns
over there and I I eat it and I'm like
the only thing I can think of is man I
just wish I had a McDonald's hasb right
now every a lot of it's very stodgy
generally like it's a lot of like just
carbs I mean the thing about the
McDonald's has brown is like yes it's
greasy I think it's like the perfect
amount of Grease to me but it's also
it's also like I don't know something
about like the thinness of this the
thinness of it as well and it's got that
sometimes it's not always like perfectly
crunchy sometimes it's a little bit
chewy but it's like soggy is the word
yeah soggy I wouldn't I wouldn't say
chewy I'm not sure it's soggy G let's be
realistic here let's be growing up it
kind of crumbles in your mouth because
it a little bit soggy I okay I don't
like hash browns if they're too crunchy
okay you you have them raw right you
don't add any shce to it no no I I have
them ra that's crazy to
me I haven't I do I I have a bite raw
and then I'm like hold on I need I need
like the vinegar of the the ketchup to
help with the oil here H sorry with the
um like yeah the vineger of ketchup to
help with the oil of the hash I don't
think ever used sauce on a hash brown
before I love catch with hash browns
it's like it's just like frost that
actually makes so much sense I don't
know why I never thought yeah why it's
literally Frost that's why hash browns
are perfect cuz they don't need [__]
ketchup in them they don't need anything
muffin doesn't need any I will admit the
of the breakfast menu the sausage
McMuffin is the best one all of the
items are red herrings you should not
order them people who get the bacon one
I don't know what the [__] is wrong with
you it is not a good item it tastes like
sh the inferior one no it tastes bad all
I'm saying is that uh you could just
remove every menu item from McDonald's
aside from the breakfast menu and
McFlurries and I will be very happy no I
I wouldn't be I live my life what the I
would be a I think I would actually
prefer that knowing that the breakfast
menu was available all day all time in
America only in America though that
ruins the Mystique of the breakfast menu
the the the reason why the breakfast
menu is so good is because you happen to
wake up with the boys and you you happen
to be McDonald's the boys at 9:55 a.m.
and you're like guys we can make it yeah
we can do it the golden five minut
you're like we it's 11 right 11 it ends
right I'm not sure time Jaan but in the
UK I think it's 11 anyway you You' made
need it in time to experience the double
MCM I think the only I think the only
time I've ever ordered a McDonald's
breakfast is when I've stayed out all
night to the point I've missed the last
train and it's like 5: in the morning
and I'm like I guess I'll go get
McDonald's that's the only time I've
gotten it you know part of the reason I
think this or if I'm want to [__]
road trip with Chris yeah CH Chris is a
McDonald's fan yeah part of the reason I
think this is
um maybe maybe this is a hot take I
don't know if it is because you know um
I just don't think McDonald's is that
good anymore I don't know wait anymore
as in like since when since I was a kid
I think I've just grown up like I I
remember like I had this point you got
[__] edgeless Pizza there what you
want talking about look I don't know if
something about me has changed but every
every time I've ordered McDonald's like
within the past four or five years yeah
I have this mental image about how it
tastes when I was a kid and then I take
a bite okay did you have McDonald's like
birthday
parties uh I don't know if I had
McDonald's birthday party but like so
then how you'd remember if you had
McDonald you would remember that' be
that's a Canon event okay the kid life I
think I went to McDonald's birthday
parties but I never had one for myself I
went to McDonald's birthday parties but
yeah I mean like I [__] love
McDonald's obviously as a kid teenager
it's just they come Fort food and you
know what you know what ruin me with
McDonald's I Al enough I think America
ruins me cuz the American McDonald's bad
no no not just the American McDonald's
buter America in general just
America eating American fast food and
and tasting how good fast food can be in
America ever since I had that like
Awakening of just like what's the golden
standard of fast food oh this is what
this is what fast food should tastes
like's the gold what's the golden
standard food fast food like what's the
best fast food American joint go best
fast food American joint even just going
to to somewhere like I don't know uh I
know Five Guys isn't in the same realm
but but just like C uh you know any kind
of
like any kind of like necessarily a
burger join right yeah I'm also thinking
about places like Chick-fil-A and you
know other like fast food establishments
ever since I had the ceiling that like
the taste of that ever since then after
after then I've tried ordering
McDonald's and that Magic's just gone I
every time I order nugs thinking oh
you're getting nuggets what's wrong with
nuggets are awful I like the Nuggets why
they're like the most tasteless piece of
rubber in your life yeah ever since I've
tasted American fast food I've gone back
to like I've just not craved McDonald's
at like anymore except for McDonald's
breakfast which is still goated and I am
completely [__] I every now and then
I get the craving to get a double
cheeseburger or a Big Mac every now and
then I'm just like I can't shake it
there is nothing else right now that
will satisfy that need than a double
cheeseburger or a Big Mac all right just
doesn't taste that good I love it it
doesn't it it doesn't taste it it kind
of like blew my mind to realize [__]
I've been programmed to like this stuff
because I liked it as a kid and then I
have like I actually bite down to have a
taste and I'm like [__] I don't think
this tastes as good as I remember it I
don't know man I don't want to hear this
coming from the guy who put the Edge
from Pizza Hut on his list I love the
[__] double cheeseburgers in McDonald
oh dude they're so good